hello people think you'll like this we
were so excited to do GTA heists and
livestream it the day it came out but
unfortunately it didn't really work
there was some connection problems but
what was cool was your dedication you
kept playing and playing you played
throughout the whole weekend and we end
up having all these awesome moments yes
yay and I want to know your top three
favorite moments of GTA hi telly first
one was actually you Andy and myself in
the Prison Break
it was the finale all I was supposed to
do was basically provide transport out
and you and Andy had to go into the
prison and you guys had the worst time
getting here he kept dying and I'm just
circling the area but it was a build-up
because the longer I was flying around
the more I realized okay when they
inevitably get out in the prison
it's on me and then it's because then
it's me basically handling the show and
it was gut-wrenching it was it was
everything I expected to be so there it
is you guys finally get through and I'm
asked to basically pinpoint a location
for a pickup obviously when to choose a
runway I'm not gonna choose like a
mountain so I choose the runway aisle
and I look behind me and there you guys
are an armored truck five stars on you
just cops just freaking out all over you
guys are screaming you guys were
literally we're all in the same room so
we were all screaming and I'm I remember
asking like what do you guys like what
cuz I had first thought you guys died
but what happened was there was a dude
because it was awesome one was just in a
buzzard helicopter all he was doing was
taking out police choppers and they were
just like falling in front of you
and that's where you guys were screaming
about anyway so you guys eventually get
to the runway I'm there the flame it's
exhilarating because this is it like I
cannot screw this up I screw this up
you guys have to do that oh [ __ ] my like
another 20 minutes yeah fighting through
that prison which was not easy task
because they kept coming wave after wave
after wave and right like what happens
and you put so much invest so much into
it you're like I'm not doing this again
right we all got the airplane once we're
starting like rolling down I knew I had
in the bag but was really funny was I
remember there were some part like hop
cars like Cummings head on that us and I
like VIN pull up intentionally just so I
could do that like last minute cinematic
like over the cop cars and Hugh even
like last second and it's a movie right
the one that was so awesome was just
another scene out of like in action
movies which was like Navy SEAL status
on a boat the middle of the night in
waves and you're storming a aircraft
carrier now this is like a new map
essentially that rocks are putting in
our aircraft carrier that you pull
around the back you sneak in with
silenced weapons you've taken out dudes
in hangars every time someone unlike the
one whoa this is what what do you see
you know like things are exploding your
game through its next you know your well
your TAS was stealing the hydrogen and
then I'm in the Hydra we take off then
they all take off in jets - and then the
task is basically to cover me from an
enemy Jets scrambling and there's huge
insane dogfight that ends we're flying
back to like drop off the plane and then
the best part is like danger zone plays
on the radio
oh this is another one where is actually
similar mission different heist where
one team is in a helicopter covering me
and another dude on a boat
we are storming the same yacht that was
in the campaign or you like your
daughters on it wherever I'm with this
dude we have like silenced shotguns
going through stealing coke you just
invert Lee are going whoa this is so
cool and then the guys in the helicopter
are like what tell me what you seen and
that was such a like awesome moment that
I was having them myself like doing
other heist missions where I would like
hearing them people going like this is
so cool and you're like describe it for
me
I'm almost done with all the heist but
it's then it's just been absolutely
exhilarating if you're playing it in the
plane one time the next time you're
gonna want to play it right in in the
prison so there's maximum replayability
for all these Heights you can just keep
playing yeah and that's my next goal you
know not being the helicopter I want to
be in the base with night-vision goggles
there's just so much extra content that
I've only heard about now I want to see
it
you